[Music]
John Wick has been about the guns it's
been about the fighting it's been about
cars from day one John Wick 4 we have
our Arctic Trion sequence where we have
fights alongside cars you've never seen
so many car hits in your life it turns
into a giant car John Wick Soup Sandwich
you're gonna be shooting you're gonna be
sliding you're gonna do a reverse 180
you're gonna do reloads in the midst of
all of that smashing people hitting
people throwing them off with like
little 180s and sending them off
everything's complicated if it's not
complicated it's easy and nothing about
John Wick is easy
John Wick 4.
[Music]
finding a car sequence in general is
complicated because you have giant
machines with people inside of them and
trying to be able to do any kind of car
sequence well takes a lot of planning
takes a lot of coordination when you add
on that somewhere like Paris where you
have traffic controls or you have
different elements pedestrians like
people coming out from car parks that
adds that extra degree of difficulty and
obviously safety is always on top of our
minds thought we're planning any
sequence like this and with the
wonderful Jonathan rothbard now VFX team
you know we were able to take just an
open area that we can fully control and
have full safety over and then be able
to create that world
and so we ended up working in this
airport in Berlin Tego that is not
operating anymore so we have this whole
experience we're doing anyway 40 sunkers
in the middle of 200 cars there's no
martial arts demonstration for that like
that that's creative Instinct logistical
hand leadership they like all like a lot
of coming together and that is the story
John Wick chapter four car food